every great comic understands how to  tell a great story and you will too  after watching this  so all great stories start in one place  and end in another just like in this bit  here of rahul's he starts low and slow  establishing the premise i hate because  every club has this one  dj  okay  i'm controlling the whole vibe of this  place and then builds to an animated act  out really driving home this premise in  a very funny and act-outy animated way  if that's a word he'll stop the music in  between  and expect you to  strongly like  really drives the point home with a big  physical act out the audience clearly  loves so remember every story has an  emotional arc and it's crucial for  comics to learn this because